Paulo wants to earn $1500
by mowing lawns.
He will charge $35 for
each lawn he mows.
What is the minimum number of
lawns the Paulo needs to mow
to reach his goal of $1500?
So we need to figure out the
minimum number of lawns that
Paulo needs to mow.
Now, whatever that number is,
that number times $35, because
that's how much he's going
to get per lawn.
So the number that he has to
mow times $35 needs to be
greater than 1,500.
So to figure out that number,
let's just divide 1,500
divided by 35.
Maybe it goes evenly, and
that'll be the number of lawn
he needs to mow.
So we're going to take 1,500
and divide it by 35 because
that's how much he gets
paid per lawn.
Now 35 does not go into 1, so we
have to add another digit.
35 does not go into 15.
35 goes into 150.
Well, 30 goes into
150 five times.
35 is bigger so it won't
go into it five times.
Let's try out 4.
Let's see if it goes
into it four times.
4 times 5 is 20.
Let's regroup the 2,
or carry the 2.
Four times 3 is 12.
12 plus 2 is 14.
Now we subtract.
0 minus 0 is 0.
5 minus 4 is 1.
The ones cancel out, and
then we bring down
this zero right here.
35 goes into 100.
Well, 35 times 2 is 70, and if
you add another-- 35 times 3
is 105, so that's too big, so
it goes into it two times.
2 times 5 is 10.
Let's carry the 1.
2 times 3 is 6 plus 1 is
7, or 35 times 2 is 70.
You subtract.
0 minus 0 is 0.
0 minus 7, you can't do it.
You could already view it as 10
minus 7, or if you want to
go in the traditional way, this
0 can take or borrow 1
from this 1, so that
becomes a 0.
This becomes a 10.
10 minus 7 is 30.
And so there's nothing
left to bring down.
so we now know that 35 goes into
1,500 forty-two times,
but there's a remainder of 30.
If he mowed 42 lawns, he'd
be 30 short of 1,500.
35 times 42 is 30
less than 1,500.
What would it be?
1,470.
So in order to make 1,500, he's
going to have to go over
it, so he's going to have to
do one more lawn than this.
So just to remind ourselves,
if we just divide-- let me
write it here.
1,500 divided by 35 is equal
to 42, remainder 30, so 42
won't be enough lawns.
We're going to have more to-- we
have 30 more bucks to earn,
so he's going to have to mow one
more lawn to get another
$35, so he's going to have
$5 left over after he
makes up this 30.
So he's going to have to mow 43
lawns if he really wants to
cross this threshold of $1500.
If he does mow the 43 lawns,
he'll have more than $1500.
He'll actually have $5
more than $1500.